[Musique]
c'est un texte est issu d'un long débat
parlementaire entre l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat qui vise
principalement à des conjugue alizés
l'allocation adulte handicapé c'est une
mesure de justice sociale que nous
portions au sein du groupe bel air ainsi
que au sein d'autres groupes politiques
du sénat parce que nous considérons que
le handicap est en situation qui est
subi et qu'il est injuste de prendre en
considération des revenus du conjoint
enlevant la notion d'autonomie aux
personnes handicapées et je pense
notamment souvent aux femmes qui sont
cités sur le handicap qui sont
directement concernés
[Musique]
le gouvernement considère que
l'allocation adulte handicapé et emme
est a minima social comme notamment le
rsa alors que nous nous considérons que
c'est une prestation de compensation
pour des gens qui sont très éloignées
voit dans l'incapacité de trouver un
emploi alors l'attitude du gouvernement
et est assez incompréhensible
je pense que c'est à l'origine avant
tout une question budgétaire et c'est
merci qui est plutôt mener le débat
puisque aujourd'hui on voit bien que
l'ensemble de la classe politique
l'ensemble des mouvements politiques en
dehors de la majorité présidentielle est
bien est favorable à ce principe général
donc ce n'est pas un débat gauche droite
c'est vraiment un élément essentiel
c'est une prestation qui est une
compensation pour des gens qui sont très
éloignés voire dans la capacité de
travailler un jour que leur situation
risque de peu évolué et donc on est plus
proche finalement d'un enjeu de sécurité
sociale que d'un enjeu de finalement de
la politique sociale du gouvernement
voilà donc une position que nous ne
comprenons pas trop et d'ailleurs je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on devrait
certainement relancer ce débat lors de
l'élection présidentielle